[Music]
when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories not
Memories new
things
I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day
for most of human
civilization we believed that life could
only
exist on the surface of our
planet what else were we wrong
about welcome to my
world W you come on
in this world has more Secret
than we could possibly imagine Miracles
I
still now and
[Music]
then what is
that that's not
Kong who could have done
this
Kong can't stop this on his
own he won't be
alone
oh welcome to my
world is that a mini
Kong whatever you have to
do however long it
takes
promise me you'll find your way
home
fosa give me this
[Music]
promise
L and
gentlemen start your
engines
oh
I'm furious the darkest of
Angels the question in
is do you have it in you to make it
[Music]
Epic
19 states have seceded the United States
Army ramps up activity the White House
issued warnings to the Western forces as
well as the Florida Alliance the free
term president assures the uprising will
be dealt with swiftly let me know if you
want to try anything on are you guys
aware there's like a pretty huge civil
war going on all across America we just
try to stay out with what we see on the
news seems like it's for the
best
citizens of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and
California have suffered a very great
defeat at the hands of the United States
military Mr President do you regret the
use of air strikes against American
citizens we moving to DC today we need
to go down there they shoot journalists
outside in the capital every Instinct in
me says this is death
what every time I survive the war zone I
thought I was sending a warning home
don't do
this but here we are there's some kind
of misunderstanding here what we
American
okay okay what kind of American are
you you don't know
the Western forces will reach the White
House on July 4 oh my god get in the car
get in the
car move move
move you're going to hang back I'm not
hanging back one
nation under God
indivisible with liberty
And Justice For Hope go go go go
go God Bless
[Applause]
America it's okay I'm here I'm here it's
been a while since you've had one of
those those nightmares tell me what was
it
about it's only
fragments nothing's
[Music]
clear you've been fighting the hurin for
decades
lo my family's been fighting them for
centuries your blood comes from Dukes
and great
houses here we're
equal what we do we do for the benefit
of
[Music]
all I'd very much like to be equal to
you maybe I'll show you the
[Music]
way deal with this Prophet send
assassins fade rur he's
psychotic
I see possible Futures all at once and
then so many futures or enemies Prevail
but I do see a way there is a narrow way
[Music]
through my allegiance is to you you
believe
me this is a form of power that our
world has not yet seen the ultimate
[Music]
power I want you to know I will love you
as long as I
breathe you will never lose me as long
as you stay who you are consider what
you're about to do for a tra is
SK this prophecy is how they enslave
us you are not prepared for what is to
[Music]
come
for
Fore
[Music]
fore
[Applause]
I'm telling you it's going to be another
hot one out there in fact there are heat
alerts in effect for New Jersey feeling
like
100°
[Music]
leaving me here on my
own what is
that
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear ducts freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
it is time to take the next step on your
journey I'm not going to be the Dragon
Warrior anymore you will advance the
spiritual leader of The Valley Of Peace
inner
peace inner peace keep your surf off my
turf dinner pleas
dinner with peas in a sesame glaze this
is not working at
[Music]
all tailong big
fan once I possess the Kung Fu of every
Master villain no one will dare question
my power not even the Great Dragon
Warrior who's that the most powerful
shape-shifting sorceress the chameleon
how do I find this the chameleon I'm
going to lead you right to her front
door against an
army then we'll just have to get an army
of our own what is this place the best
Crooks and criminals live here you're a
wanted criminal you sound surprised is
it
surprising now you kids be careful with
those
fireworks silence makes our tummies
tingle why should we help you we can we
take down the chameleon together being
the Dragon Warrior it's who I am SC what
do I know about being a spiritual leader
what is it you're holding a cookie you
were chosen to become something more
than you already
[Music]
are how should we do this quick and
painless or slow and painful slow and
painful
you finally met your match chameleon
We're Not So Different you and
I stand back I'm going to kick my
butt
Army
[Music]
Hi Well lookie lookie she is the perfect
fit I promise did she even see you she
was about
to what are you doing don't do
this no no no
[Music]
hi oh God
starts this is just so exciting what is
happening well that's a perfectly
understandable question give num I'm an
if get it imaginary friend our kids grew
up so we need new ones you could save
all of us all of who and don't say IFS
let him say it or I think his head may
actually
explode
[Music]
fine thank you you ready for
this there's no telling who's behind
that door
today we have to help them yes we
do
to not going to ask you again put some
pants on you're freaking everyone
out starting to see why I live Al
along
CH kind of a kid creates an invisible if
[Music]
don't uh don't don't look him in the
eye which one you know damn well which
one thanks for doing this it really
means a whole
lot
[Music]
scared
do when we all fall asleep do we go kiss
no he didn't when we were fixing up the
pool
stop they said it hadn't been used in 15
years maybe they weren cool
people this is now for the
camps used to be scared of
pools cider come on
cider get a Vibe here do you have a
boyfriend no hey someone's coming over
in a minute
keep your mouth shut
Marco you need to say something
back Ronin
Marco why aren't you say
anything
my kids have seen
things and I'm worried something is
happening to my
husband dad hav been looking for
you there has to be some way to stop
this
marot
Marco
[Music]
Mar you're a blessing Mr Clay this place
was crab grass and weeds and you brought
it back to
life Mrs Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this here today she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three 1 2
three there I did it for
you no you can't take it no you can't
I'm going to burn this place to
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct
we have laws for these things until they
fail then you have
me my fingers he cut them off what the
[__] bro don't move you're
going bow
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scam you're going
get the money's going all over the world
to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming here straight
through the back entrance I figured i'
give the 5 as a break somebody detain
this
guy die we have to kill him before he
kills his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as [__] who
[Music]
knew what's your name CYO sweet I'm Mr
Miller I'm assuming that you got one of
these before I read the whole list well
there's 12 books on that list Bary
heart said
I what is an
adult I'm
18 languishing in the Wilds of nowhere
Tennessee break C don't you get scared
walking through those woods I'm the
scariest thing in
there never knew could be
speechless I want you to write a short
story in the style of your favorite
author are you offering me special
treatment Mr Mill well
uh John here is prepping her to be his
Transcendent is she pretty oh she's
talented damn even worse what are you
wring about I've been inspired I've had
no achievement make him love you I'll
set fire to the whole place
I don't know she opened her mouth to say
[Music]
something but the words fell
away why did you write this this is
inappropriate write what you know is
what you said if you don't rewrite this
I'll have to feel
you I dare
you it's like he's been living in Gray
scale and you're the first thing he's
ever seen in color
you are the adult show some
responsibility you're my student and I'm
your teacher that's
all if she can convince them had
something happened between us I could
lose my job it's not all you could lose
you're going to ruin his life burn it
down it down it
down in your ownwards how did it start
said I was a good
[Music]
kid oh hell
no [__] move hey PG-13
please what was that Lord is the queen
be Regina George don't look her in the
ey you could be really hot if you change
like
everything welcome to Health and Human
Sexuality we will be getting an
abstinence course Then followed by in
the spring condoms and choking you're
learning things now that I don't know
how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet Baby
E we as women have to be able to support
each other get in loser welcome Katie
you're never going to believe what I
found this morning you're burn book mom
go make snacks for sure for sure Regina
yeah do you like gum sure oh no I don't
have any I was just you're a mess we
will help you
caddy why are you dressed so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
[__] that is [__] shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay all we've done is to make Regina
hotter and revive the wet look dance
break who wrote all this
[Music]
JN Katie pushed her Regina really should
be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't even
see it like a face
breast k inor you have to pick a French
name Chanel
No No
beon in 3 2
[Music]
action so good oh good good good sh to
the heart
and and you love bad name anyone but him
I didn't approve him you know that you
are literally the last person on Earth I
want to see it slap the [__] out of you
I really could and I'm open to that in a
safer
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stunky
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guye
we need to keep it super profesh profesh
is my middle name you said your middle
name was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster there it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back oh Jody movie is dead why me you're
a stump man nobody's going to notice you
that's your job no offense I mean some
taking you find Ryder save Jody's film
you get the love of your life back I'm
not the hero I'm just the dou not today
you're
not Tom we need you back on set
pal
you dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail
he was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
chasing board
[__] the they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you make it you
can make it you can't make it it's too
dangerous goty stairs
okay what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love I'll BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core yeah
boy
what you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy margarit
make some bad decisions
yes sh the heart and you're to
[Applause]
lame I've been
thinking I can't run this club
forever
I built this for
nothing this is my
[Music]
family you and me
kid from the
beginning yes
pleas I was a golden age bike rider I
never felt so out of place in all my
life that's when I saw him for the first
time and took my breath away I'm
[Music]
Benny 5 weeks later I married
him I thought I could change him you
know not to be different but to be I
don't know like he's
wild hey told you to take that jacket
off you'd have to kill me to get this
jacket
off what about the
bar find it
down the club got real big real fast
they started running drugs gambling
prostitution is that what this club is
now I want you to quit writing don't ask
that
Benny I need
here you can't have him if he wants to
ride a bike you ride a bike oh
yeah oh yeah
[Music]
hey you know I'm
just just think it over you
know I certainly hope you dance as well
as you
dress there's only one way to find
out
[Music]
on you and I we're not so different
agent oh
go it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother H it's called a
copout
whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series Ellie
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what is
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this
book
come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked a
hornet nest you didn't even know existed
I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that
[Music]
cat it's time for you to meet
the real agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh my
[Music]
God
oh
oh hi there little
buddy
[Music]
you hungry little
guy you want a little
[Music]
more and that's how I adopted
John okay now have you ever been with a
plate don't please no ow it's so hot
it's really hurting ow ow ow you deserve
to
[Music]
be say when never John bury me and
cheese oh I apologize in advance the
eating you're about to see will not be
pretty and if you have young children
this would be a good time for them to
leave the room you never see
nobody hey Junior this is Big my father
you ever jumped a train I've never
jumped here's I stop really
where oh OD you think he'd see that
coming let's get it I deserve to be with
somebody
me
[Music]
L welc to
hos
spee
fore
[Music]
ham
for the
[Music]
project
hold
for
okay a
[Music]
chaos
you have to save yours and our
reputation the DEA murders in Silverado
remember that yeah two undercover agents
killed in a drug buy we're
DEA I got the marshals to agree to send
you down and bring those two witnesses
back
[Music]
here sometimes I mess around with movie
lines you looking at me mhm there's
nobody else around here
[Music]
we got a doctor fix you up the right
way this is my brother it's dangerous
the longer we here the more danger for
your family Joon has a few lives left
he's a strong
one she can help solve who killed those
DEA agents in America we can protect no
you
can't I saw what happened that night and
they know
it so who do you know that you trust
that you can
call so many questions my
friend
if you want to fight with the Wolves you
got to be a
[Music]
wolf hey come on get your stuff let's
go
let's try that
[Music]
again a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who are
running out of it until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back the land
that we're
living I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want
me New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you why who are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day you have no idea what those girls
have
come I think he can see into the future
are he's trying to change what
happens do you get
down why aren't you scared
why do your future was almost so
different if you want to live you have
to trust
me get
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
little
[Music]
our little girls growing up so fast and
things couldn't be
better what is
that
I okay let's clear it all out it's demo
day demo wait what's happening who are
you
people what's going
on wait wait you
can't hey hey what are you doing all
right she's aesome that was
what orange who made the console orange
do I look orange I didn't touch it
orange is not my color not
me hello oh my gosh I'm anxiety where
can I put my stuff a new emotion wow oh
I'm sorry we wanted to make such a good
first impression what do you mean
[Music]
we there's a young
man I talk to him I wish had a spin
[Music]
you that's really weird
Lisa Taffy says it's a waste of time to
try and fix it while he better just
accept the guy fls oh that's so
cute
[Music]
I can't do that not until we bury the
body
now I can't be
saved and in the next life there
remember me remember
me
[Music]
really hope this goth phase in
soon we all know anything can happen out
there sometimes we feel
lost we push and we suffer
we keep going that makes all the
difference hey what happened to you boy
you don't look so good meall look
somebody likes my meatballs they Paw
Patrol we got a race to win just
remember Michael this race doesn't
Define you I raced for 19 years this is
my last chance to win 3 2 1 there's a
young boy living in the city all
was over the next 10 days these athletes
will cross 400 Mi climbing biking and
kaying D dot is Daddy go daddy
dot let's talk I gave the meatball 3
days 200 miles ago lead the stupid dog
and let's go come on move dumb dog what
is it
boy oh oh God can't believe I almost
walked right off that Cliff extra
meatballs for you my
friend he's hurting what do you think he
went through before he met us whatever
it was it wasn't good how the hell did
he get all the way from here to there
while we were on by and zip lines and
running and climbing he must have wings
we don't know about boy you know I'm
back like I never left you want to try
to embase the buckets of pain I need a
bigger bucket team broad rail has
traveled over 200 miles and they found a
companion Daddy has a dog what have you
done think you found your new partner in
suffering Michael yeah he's the keing I
think we should call him Arthur AR of
the
king how's he doing he's been through so
much
this bck needs a vet I don't want you to
hurt
anymore he's a
fighter just like
you famous dog that'ss even worse than
the rest of you maybe you all deserve
each other always underestimated aren't
we
buddy this isn't the route on the map
it's okay just follow Arthur lead the
way
[Music]
King I've never seen anything like this
everybody knows about
[Music]
it guess what I'm not a dog
person when I hold a brick in my
hand I know exactly where it is and what
it will
do this form is its function
that gives me
peace can I help you I'm the brick
layer sir this is urgent what am I
looking at Victor radic we need to bring
Vil out of
retirement what do you want and an old
friend stop by to say hello someone's
trying to Blackmail the CIA he can bring
down our entire Global
Network that's why I want you to go to
Greece to fix it with her it's a big
assignment for you first time in the
field no
supervisors I'm the supervisor of course
you
[Applause]
are so what's our move have to find him
and end
this you should have stayed where you
were cuz now that you're
back it's going to be hard for you to
leave again
clearly
[Music]
I warned you not going to get
involved you can't hide from me I'll
never ever stop
[Music]
coming oh little less colone next time
yes
dear
[Music]
we're going on a Manhunt not building a
chimney never do a job without my
tools wait
oh hi
hey tshi Duncan just going to turn a
whole family into
millionaires should I have a fashion
line a
[Music]
foundation you're incredible today thank
you I mean it wasn't even like tennis it
was an entirely different
game hey come hang out with us later
want me come tuck you in no we just keep
talking n
how often does this happen going after
the same girl not as often as you think
we usually have different types so
you're saying I should be flattered
aren't you everybody's
type come here which one of
[Music]
us he's not in love with you what makes
you think I want someone to be in love
with me it's nice to see you lit up
about something even if it's my
girlfriend it's got his coach tshi
Donaldson who also is his wife I'm
playing for both of us
tshi I think maybe we disturbed by the
fact that she could have been in someone
like me when we were teenagers when we
were teenagers hey I love
you I know
you don't know what tennis
is it's a
relationship we went somewhere really
beautiful
together I'm taking such good care of my
little white
boys I assume you planned this not this
part but
it I like
it won't you H to
sin these songs are Freedom cuz all I
ever
have Redemption
songs when you write
that all my
life
are you ready for B barley and
the that's a hit is the people
music you know you're a
superstar I am a
superstar you can't separate the music
and the message you see reg music come
for unify the people not Everyone likes
what you're saying for your own safety
you need to
[Music]
stop on December 3rd 1976 would be
assassins invaded Bob Marley's home and
attempted to take the life of the singer
his wife and don't worry about that
don't
worry that every
going to be all right you like that one
yeah there's a war going on oh I can
bring peace I can't even get peace for
myself r
upile
[Music]
with
sometimes the messenger has to become
the
message
Bob I know it's
dangerous but you're the only one who
can unite the
people you're ready
Bob no guns can stop this
message I want the World to
[Music]
Change and that time is no
[Applause]
this is my message to
you the cas
Santos not on your life
hello
girls it's the last body shot
competition so we are going to Salt you
up I've had it with love I don't believe
it's relevant to the 21st century
lesbian you're not wearing that I just
came from work I came from Toledo I
don't dress like it I'm not here to
Pedal my
wees I'm leaving town I am too that was
my plan where are you going tassy
Florida I've been unhappy that's why we
take this trip together honey babe get
our act together together Curly's
driveway Pennsylvania's most trusted
name in car delivery cly here don't call
me
curly and your name curly my name is
Curly we just met it's too
familiar we're here for the car wait a
minute you call with a drop off in
Tallahassee and then these broads come
in and say they're ready to go to
Tallahassee they drive the car instead
of you is that bad bad if they find the
goods
what we should see what's in here I bet
it's
[Music]
[Applause]
locked I understand that you're unhappy
sir we will find and deliver the package
we just want your
friends you cannot relate to the public
which in the service profession is a big
handicap did the two creeps find you
they know we have their stuff maybe back
shake them down are they like wanted or
something oh no they're not in trouble
at all I'm going to help you break a big
murder case that is about the dumbest
thing I've ever heard and I'm a
cop who are you
Democrats well you've had a full
day how does it feel being back good I
had such good memories here maybe my
happy place can be our happy place we
left you all alone down
here I'm playing a new game with chany
the scavenger hunt list that's fun
Chanty says you're not allowed to play
with us oh because you left him I need
something happy something
happy G I thought bugs freaked you out
if I can finish my list try will take me
on a trip to the place he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice you've been spending time with a
new friend
[Music]
he asked you to do something that hurt
you that was part of the game does that
seem like a game a good friend would
want to play maybe we shouldn't play
together anymore chy maybe we shouldn't
be friend no no no
no Alice Alice Alice Alice Alice
Alice
she's lost but we're going to find
her every culture has entities that
tether to the young we call them
imaginary
friends you are always playing with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes
enraged he says he's right behind
you but it was just my
can I hang out with your imaginary
friend he's not
imaginary and he's not your
[Applause]
friend you taught your dad
somebody
[Music]
why give us a
call so where did you appear
[Music]
from
Oklahoma I've never been anywhere but
here but where you you doing with that
big
girl get a lot of crazy ass foreigners
mostly how's it going
guys this here is Jackie hi she needs a
job say she'll do anything yeah you like
guns not really what the [__] you doing
here
then I'm a bit more powerful in a
punch [__] yeah call me when it's
done
what is this
place huh you don't
understand get back in the
carun they found a
body looks like you've got your hands
full don't regret
this will just need to fight
back I'm going to tell them everything
you ever did FBI open up are you
threatening
me
yep that was really stupid
honey no never for
[Music]
okay
I know you can feel their discomfort
Aaron watching me walk through a room
full of white people was the most
painful thing I've ever seen excuse me
sorry I don't want to take you to a job
interview there's a recruiting class
starting right now and we got to get you
in
it welcome to the American
Society of magical
Negroes I don't really understand it's
easier to
sh what's the most dangerous animal on
the planet sharks white people when they
feel uncomfortable white people feeling
uncomfortable precedes a lot of bad
stuff for us that's why we fight white
discomfort every day because the happier
they are the safer we are the name these
a little updating maybe like
magical black people or I guess that
doesn't have the same
ring you ready oh wow your first client
is a Jason M his morale is far too low
hey hey darn it I was hoping there was a
station right next to him oh is this one
spoken for no yeah it's actually fun and
weirdly relaxing it's like being a
secret agent with none of the danger hey
I'm lizy nice to meet you nice to meet
you she's great yeah she's cool you
kidding come on man she's smart and
funny I know what you were doing going
on about her you're trying to set us up
no no no that's not what I was doing you
cannot have a relationship with Lizzy
now because if you don't put Jason first
everyone's magic will
fail I've always felt like it's my job
to make white people feel comfortable
and here it literally
is but maybe it shouldn't be I got a
great plan to ask her out but I'm going
to need your help do you think you can
like work your magic hey is you talking
about me hey oh my wait are you but I A
Long
Way someone to F the society who was it
you didn't let her go like I told you if
you interfere with her or your client
you could have your memory erased you
won't even remember she
existed even though we might never see
each other again I need you to know that
what we had was
real I'm curious to see how you going to
make it out of all
this
Peter
Barrett excuse me my name is
Sophia and my mom called you Peter
biometric watch contains a hard drive
with sole access to his contacts stolen
Intel and we want it all back she wanted
you to find someone named Peter my
name's Mark I wish I could be more help
you were CIA like my mom right you're a
really good painter oh hey kid stop
those are private this is her this is my
mom so you do know
[Music]
her go upstairs last Dar left the
bathroom lock the door and get the
tub what's
[Music]
happened you are Peter Barrett how'd you
find by
me what do you know about Peter Barrett
the painter the boy murdered eight
federal agents in Cold Blood what I am
looking for
someone it's me Peter where are you can
I trust you two agents show up my
doorstep today asking about
you he's hiding
something I'm the only one who can
protect you tell me about the people who
came to kill me she thinks that you're
in possession of something that poses a
major threat to our national
security I'm going to find out who took
your mother away from you and then and
then he'll do what he does mind if I
borrow a few
things
I don't want to do this
[Music]
[Applause]
kid my son never show
Mercy they are
pray we are
predators Bo your mother is
dead she died because you sent her away
she was weak sick in her mind you know
my business
yes power is about
strength if you show weakness
you will give our enemies an
opening Sho
Sho he's weak like his mother leave
him what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this
Hunter they say he uses a connection
with animals to track his
prey once you're on his
list there's only one way off there's
six of us there only one of you there's
six of you
[Music]
now why do you hunt my father puts evil
into the
world I take it out
[Music]
think you some kind of Honor we were
exactly like our father just another man
hunting for a
trophy we're
murderers isn't that what he taught
us you don't get to do that to me
anymore Mr
tlin Mr
tlan where's Mr tlin oh you're standing
in
him you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out
now there is an animal I needan ofas
don't you want to know why they call me
the
rhino
America loves a
superstar I'm Jason 2 J's Jennings I was
a football legend but once you reach the
Mountaintop of greatness everybody wants
to see you
fall two days this gu smoked damn you
pled guilty to charges of speeding and
damage to city property I'm recommending
commun service with the Long Beach
Recreations department I thought I was
getting like some Martha Stewart kind of
treatment you too good for the community
that raised you
froma I am football legend Jason 2J
Jennings your new head coach Legend let
me get a picture with y'all real quick
for twiter some of y'all going to get
some girlfriends with this right
here Kei Karine Jason I've been trying
to get back to touch with you for years
I know you've been thinking about me and
I know you've been trying to get in
touch with me is that pretty much right
you just put a gun in my head relax Jay
the safety was on oh no it was on what
imagine
that before we can be the best we got to
master the
fundamentals pretty boy you missing pass
after pass you got on all that sweet ass
swag the next time you come out here
acting like a fake ass rapper we going
to kick your ass out the field stop
acting like you got an album coming
out JJ how you liking this game coach
this is a mess I don't know what I'm
doing do you remember what you were like
when you showed up freshman year you
were pain in the ass I don't owe nobody
nothing sound just like me you really
want to win a game stop pushing away
your
team let's
go it look like a black princess layer
underdogs all three underdogs on Me 1 2
3 what's my
name
[Music]
I got your masc right here be killer and
squa two dos for two jeans I found them
chained up in the back of the winner
[Music]
snitch
all
[Music]
and
child
[Music]
Santa
okay we are recording the World Rally
Championship has become the number one
TV sport in the world we're joined by
lcha team manager chesare f AO reing is
like a war and I'm the commander of an
army Walter ah Des you've got a
competitive car this year yeah very
incredible Car Central engine light car
very special materials four-wheel drive
no no no no no two wheel drive you can't
beat them with a normal
car yes we
can if you drive
it give me one good reason why I should
accept because We Are The Underdogs Jo
CH thinks he can challenge us without a
four wi RVE they SP was Ice what you
think you still think that the JS are
only technology in an organization don't
you don't believe all the cliches view
you welcome to the opening of the 51st
Monte Carlo
rally rallying is a dangerous sport does
anything frighten you one thing
losing go
[Applause]
now we have the second stage in
to let's go with that car you will never
win against me the drivers why do they
risk their
lives death is afraid of those who
pursue
it to win I'll do whatever I have to do
I'll only do six races take it or even
Watcher nowy play it all out in one last
stage wter you must recover 10 seconds
it's now never push push
push you okay I'm just thinking about
what
[Music]
winning I'm clear
I'm not a man without fault I played the
cards I was
de Clans in spite of your selfish ways
there is a beautiful soul in there
somewhere it's him Jesus of Nazareth I'm
not you can't even buy Power like that
I'm not I want to be like that in 10
[Music]
years I want to be like that now
now knowledge is stronger than
belief plant you need the Miracles I
have a
plan I can see I can
see God sent me to deliver his message
Mah I am your new
Messiah
BL my swne ah stop
that your God is a
myth see for yourselves there is no
Messiah parents if you'll be so kind to
walk on
water
damn
I you
I was fully dreading coming to this
wedding until you showed
up could I get a cranberry juice with
ice and vodka when I first saw you I
thought that we should have sex in the
code
closet
yeah
[Music]
wait hold on I am kind of in a weird
place yeah you're in a beach club coat
closet do you think that we could just
talk for a
minute romantic humiliations it's my
specialty I don't care first person to
ever go down on me we just going to
steamroll right on through I came in my
own
eye okay go
on I've had too many girlfriends over
the past couple years I can't figure it
out yeah we've all been there tell me
what I'll give you some of this pie if
you tell me more about your
[Music]
past it's not like I don't come with my
own complications we're engaged
oh wait you were
engaged lasted 13 days impressive that
is incredibly insulting I see what you
mean will you welome to the train
station I actually have class no you
don't I like this she's really hot I
know just wish I would have ended things
more
gracefully you ever see her
again this would never work you are
someone who cannot be counted on you've
run out on every guy you've ever been
with I'm a mess and I don't have any
answers but maybe you and I could figure
it out
[Applause]
together
usually I feel so alone in my memories
but it's different with
you I'm happy to tell you a few more
embarrassing stories about my love life
well I promise not to laugh [__] I
promise not to laugh
[Music]
much